they're pleased as punch as they say um
what's what's crack-a-lackin well time
the streets
i'm glad you asked what are the kids
saying mostly the n-word
okay but i'll tell you what's
crack-a-like actually i
i you know i pride myself on having my
finger on the pulse
of what the young people are saying i
can tell you
exactly what the kids are saying right
now what's that but mom you said we
could get mcdonald's you promised
i don't want to eat bread you said
mcdonald's you said we were gonna go to
mcdonald's
you know something's never changing
war never changes mcdonald's never
changes well i will tell you what else
is crack-a-lacking just because you know
of uh
all the impending doom with terms of
youtube and d-live and all these
channels
uh today i made us a uh trovo account
whoa game changer trovo dot live slash
revenge of the assist look i'm just
putting it out they never
had a problem with censorship again
yeah no matter you move around from land
to land uh so yeah so trovo dot live
slash revenge of assist you can still
watch us all the other same places
but uh just another place just another
place to go
to hang out it reminds me of uh
when jon stewart years ago on the daily
show
made some joke about you know moses and
you know getting the jews out of the
promised land you know out of
egypt and into the promised land and
they took him through the desert and he
was like and then they finally found the
promised land
and nothing bad ever happened to jews
ever again
[Laughter]
so we're good now we're fine and we're
untouchable
what are you gonna do we're on trovo now
trovo sounds like a discount travel app
it from being fair
yeah it does but get hotels and your
rental cars all in one place at
trovo.com
it looks like a carbon copy of d-live
hi i'm dean kane for trovo
who don't get like a d superman
he died of the horse and he broke his
neck and then he died and no that was
christopher reeve
oh no he's different he was tv superman
oh a tv superman so tom wellington who
would
who would be the drovos spokesperson hi
i'm lorenzo llamas
star of renegade and i'm here to tell
you about
the all-new exciting discount travel app
trovo
so uh somebody says this place runs a
lot better than d life looks like five
people on it of course [ __ ]
true i'm just looking i'm checking out
mike i'm checking out the trovo chat
today
that's right be checking that out you
get over to the trovo chat so i could
read your chats you could check out the
the icky poopoo youtube chat hi folks
peter scolari for trouble
just to see how our people are getting
it now hey kevin
it's danny bonaducci and i want to talk
to you about
trovo hi i'm lucy lawless do you like
saving money on airline tickets
i'd like to tell you about trovo
thinking of every
terrible 90s sitcom character
uh so oh hey hi someone said hi royce on
on the exclusive trovo chat that we're
checking out today
i want to see how it runs mike i want to
see how it runs boy
this is tommy flanagan for trovo
i've got a scar on my face
and it's the only thing you can look at
when i'm in a film or a tv show oh
[ __ ] yeah is that all you look at when
you see tommy planting you like that's
how you're the guy with the skirt
that's all that's all i could see it's
like joaquin phoenix with his hair lip
it's all i can stare at hi this is judy
tenuta can i take your order today
hi this is elaine boozler patrovo
you know when i go do the charlie good
nights in raleigh
i hate spending too much on airline
tickets
oh [ __ ] that's our first day on trovo
we're just making fun of you thanks
trovo i'm sorry trovo oh yeah this is
yeah you know how they run you know how
d-live has crypto and like youtube you
get money sure here you get frequent
flyer miles
if you do a good show so a little bit
will be able to fly we'll be able to fly
to atlanta
for the record i'm i am now dead set on
if if there's so many other platforms
doing this successfully
i am i am now mentally going down the
road of like
how can we do a [ __ ] a
a streaming platform with in-house
currency everyone else is doing it
people seem to be making it work and i
feel like with a selective
uh a selective guest list a velvet rope
if you will
we might be able to pull it off i have
an idea two words for you
ponzi scheme okay i like it i haven't
thought it through but i want to rob
people
well that no i'm not even kidding i want
to everything's based on crypto and
blockchain now and i know
i know for a fact that with the right
brains
we could actually make a streaming
platform a very very i don't want a big
one
a small streaming platform just for our
friends
that's powered by crypto that i can pump
and dump
and that's what i'm really interested in
would be to
artificially inflate the value of this
crypto
and dump it in increments with insider
knowledge
that other people don't have and then
buy it back cheaper when it sounds legal
actually oddly enough to answer your
question royce not illegal because
crypto's not a security
yet not illegal not yet yet and until
the sec rules on xrp's whole deal
it's not a security yet so we can pump
and dump as much as we want they're
calling it ham coin already
cam coin i like it there are money of a
ham coin hi guys i'm zachary ty brian
for trovo
and i'm here to tell you about this
amazing new
app where you can stream
rhetoric and get airline tickets for
cheap
i don't know i mean that actually sounds
like a good idea yeah
all the other big multinationals have
more than one subsidiary
all right so a lot of people here are in
the
you know what i call it mike the trovo
family
you know what i call them what no i'm
not doing it it's too early
say what you said in the car mike
um so now that we got trovo all set and
i'll be plugging that
a little bit just i want you know just
look it takes a second to subscribe
you [ __ ] never know when we'll be
popped anywhere that's just that's the
way life goes that's right folks and
take it from me
patrick duffy trovo is the number one
site for
streaming games and racist jokes and
getting airline tickets
who's sam raimi's brother he's but not
his brother
he puts some always puts in what if he
just calls him that himself that in the
commercial
hi i'm sam raimi's brother for trovo
and you go why didn't you say your real
name nobody would know me by my real
name
uh he always puts him in his movies
what's his name
ted raymie hey i'm ted raymie ted
raymond there you go
dead raimi all right the guy did
somebody remember sam raimi he made the
best superhero movie spider-man 3.
it's a very good movie and by the way
just want to savor the record don't
worry guys
i'm not going to keep interrupting the
show by running this video to the ground
and he is it's just i'm already i am
mentally and emotionally prepared for it
hi y'all i'm thomas michael ford you
might remember me from martin
i play tommy anyway i want to tell you
about airline tickets
and i put the 18 plus tag on too just so
we don't have any problems
hey you know what we could do i think
this is a good idea stick of caramels
[ __ ] leave this [ __ ] country behind
for all these dumbass millennials to
[ __ ] suffer in forever
i was just i was gonna say we could just
check out what's happening on trovo but
i mean
hey guess what guess who's on the front
page of trovo right now
your boys so you could say why do they
come to me to die
why do they come to me to die you're
like i was just gonna look at
trovo your boys are on the front page of
trovo right now
what a benchmark accomplishment hold on
can i tell you who we're up here with
we're up here with alberian oh no that's
just
that's just wait no what is uh we're up
here with
n3039 and he's all like four corners
t-boot yeah well you wanna you wanna
check in on one
yeah you're gonna click and it's just
gonna be some guy playing gta online and
going
i don't understand why we cannot just
cleanse them from our country
you know i play video games and i just
pray that my government
er click cleanse and
oh [ __ ] what is this
we have a rich history of being invaded
by russia over and over again i love
that you're translating this is amazing
he [ __ ] nailed it this is exciting
day we
here in slovakia just got gta online
i'm going to welcome my name is uh
my name is uh markell and uh you are
watching my game stream
uh unboxing i will be unboxing uh the
brand new game here gta 4
that we just get here in slovakia
i like it because protagonist sounds
just like me
and remember whenever you get your new x
when your new ps5s make sure you send
your ps4s over there they need them of
course
they're still using 360s over there so
also you can now start shipping your
keep america great shirts over there too
i'm sure hold on baseblower says
hi i'm thomas nicholas from such hood
films as a kid in keane arthur's court
and thanks to trovo my second mortgage
has been easier to manage than a grocery
bill
yeah exactly um
cool so i see um page of trouble my
favorite is he's like
i don't understand i am here at shipping
container
there's no girls in it every shipping
container i see in my country i see
girls go into shipping container
along with cases of vodka and new
mercedes-benz
this is a good way to ingratiate
yourself to like the new community
let's check out another one uh let's do
this one playing fifa i think
oh my god
hello i'm television actor and famous
stephen collins the dad from seventh
heaven and i'd like to tell you about
trovo
i'd like to say staffordshire
there had to be at least one person in
the chat that's autistic enough to go
stephen collins nice reference
uh so yeah that's that's true we can
move on i i just wanted to
i don't understand this is
so many moms here we just
we could cleanse them
there it is all right there's the link
for you guys that want to
whatever go check out there and then
like what is there like they have lemons
and d lives so what does trovo have
since it seems to be a lot of
elixir slavic people are they is it
figs is it dates is it it's honestly
called elixir
that's gay like lemons were cool
at least lemons were a unit of
measurement and an elixir
so like instead of like okay so like
instead of um
giving like ninja genies and stuff they
you you what you do is a magic spell
a fortune spin how about you just give
me my money
how may i stop be making this into a fun
game
imagine you worked at a job right and
like you worked all week or whatever and
then you come in and you go like all
right where's my paycheck
and they're like well we don't have
paychecks here we have elixir and spells
but you get to spin the wheel and you're
like i don't want to spend the i want my
money
i just worked all week so so here's a
question i have so if the youtubers in
front of the bus d-life's the back of
the bus
trovo's the kids that walk to school so
congratulations trovo you're the kids
that have to walk to school
no trovo with like the truants that you
have to actually go send people to go
get
you're right we used to have them we
used to have truant officers chasing us
and it was funny because
like you'd all cut school and it'd be
like 15 kids that are like 13
on a [ __ ] tuesday in the middle of
the afternoon
hanging out like smoking cigarettes in
front of a bodega
and like all of a sudden you just hear
hey and you see the truman officer
coming
everybody was just scattering knocking
chairs over running it was kind of like
i'm sure your school had it in high
school but there was like the smoking
section oh yeah
you never be outside smoking and
whatever and then once the security
guard would show up everyone would dump
their [ __ ] their cigarette
on the floor and just run we had a spot
but we uh
they ended up getting very clever at
keeping an eye on it to the point where
we it stopped being the spot
and we hit this black guy in junior high
school as a security guard
and also he went there i think he was a
retired cop no i think he legit did go
to our school
like when he but he was like older so it
had to be like in the 70s
but he was like some retired cop and you
could tell this dude had played football
or something when he was younger because
he was one of those
tall lean black guys with a fro
like he had a 70s style but this dude
man
any security guard you could get away
from except this one this dude still had
the speed well jimmy the
give me the greek i'll tell you why dude
he would [ __ ] and it was crazy right
because kids could get
kids could get a good head start like
you could get that burst
and be faster than him but this dude did
some kind of like
like mongoose like athlete stride
where it took the first 10 steps but
once he got to the 10th step
it was he was like he ran like the t1000
and it was like oh no and he met
that guy had the highest [ __ ] rate of
capture instead of anybody in the school
i remember looking back at him one time
and we were like two-thirds of the way
across the football field
and i was like holy [ __ ] we beat the son
of a [ __ ] and then i turned around i
started running and i made it maybe
another 10 yards
and i felt like [ __ ] back of my
hoodie and i was like
how the [ __ ] did he get so [ __ ] far
again jimmy the greek i'll tell you how
you got so far uh as far as
getting monetized so we to get
monetized pat you have to be a level one
all you need to be a level one and
street have streamed for five
hours and have 20 followers but you
already have 20 followers you have to
buy you know by by the end of this week
will be monetized on trovo
you will also get special badge if you
remove
from my country uh level level 0 you get
14 days of clip storage which is better
than d
live level one you get
i don't know if there's a let's see more
14 days of clip storage level two
30 days of clip storage yeah i mean i'll
make one but
it's not difficult just make it i just
make it no i know but i'm not gonna like
i'm done putting energy into new
platforms
uh trovo dot live slash day wave two i
made one for day wave
all right let's um let's move on here